Now that we know each phase must
increase the length of the shortest
augmenting path by at least two.
We are now ready to bound
the number of phases.
Specifically, the number of
phases used by Hopcroft- karp
is Order square root of V.
Note that the trivial bound saying
that there can be only one phase
per possible augmenting path
link isn't good enough.
That would still leave us
with an order V bound.
In reality, we will have a phase for
length 1, for length 3, probably for
length 5, maybe not for
length 7, and so forth.
But as we consider greater and
greater possible phase lengths,
the ones for which for
which we will actually have augmenting
phases gets sparser and sparser.
The key argument will be that after
roughly square root of V phases,
the path length will be at
least square root of V.
And that then will imply that we only
have square root of V phases left.
To fill out the argument,
we'll let M prime be the matching
found by Hopcroft- karp.
And we'll let M be the matching after
the ceiling of the square root of the V
phases.
Because each phase increased
the shortest augmenting path by 2,
the length of the shortest
augmenting path in M
is at least twice the square
root of V plus 1.
And hence, no path in the symmetric
difference between M and
M prime that is augmenting for
M can have shorter length.
This implies that they're at most the
size of V divided by this shortest path
length, augmenting paths for
M in this symmetric difference here.
We just run out of vertices,
there aren't enough left to fill
out any more paths than this.
And if there can be only so
many augmenting paths in the difference,
then M can't be too
far away from M prime.
Certainly, at most the square root of V.
Hence, M will only be augmented
square root of V more times,
meaning that there can't be more than
the square root of V more phases.
We have square root of V phases to make
all the augmenting paths long enough.
So that there can be only square root
of V possible more augmentations,
and that completes the theorem.
Overall then, we've just shown that
Hopcroft- karp finds a maximum matching
in time Order E times
the square root of V.
We only had square root of V phases.
And each phase, because of the clever
way we were able to reuse the level
graph, only ends up using Order E time.
And this result is
actually the best known.